autre manifestation celle des
infirmières de l'éducation nationale
c'est devant l'assemblée nationale que
plusieurs dizaines d'infirmières du smic
fsu se sont mobilisés pour lancer un
appel à la grève
plusieurs revendications une
revalorisation salariale
un recrutement plus important mais aussi
plus de reconnaissance pour leur
profession écouté et on est rassemblée
parce que on dénonce depuis déjà
longtemps les conditions de travail qui
se dégradent et qui sont encore
dégradées avec la crise sanitaire
et puis on dénonce aussi des réunions
des rémunérations qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur de nos missions sont ni de
service qu'on rend pour les élèves
les infirmières de l'hôpital ont été
revalorisées dans le cadre du ségur de
la santé il ya un domaine de l'éducation
et nous on est les grandes oubliées et
on va être les infirmières aimons bien
mais ya dix ans alors qu'on a des
missions extrêmement étendue les
infirmières depuis
l'aco vides ont été très sollicités
participer activement à
au suivi des familles suivies des
enfants sont sollicités pour diverses at
et cela prend beaucoup de temps sur
leurs missions prioritaires
quels qu'ils sont quand même l'accueil
des élèves et le suivi notamment de ses
élèves qui avec la commune vont encore
plus mal